and the right guy on the mound to start
the home stand old uncle charlie number
50 adam wainwright 88 pitches complete
game last time out
3-2 on the way on the ground through for
a base hit adamus keeps on hitting and
you might be able to hear there are a
lot of brewers fans in the ballpark
tonight
so it brings in yelich the 0-2 pitch
he struck him out on three pitches
never swung the bat and the 1-1 by
wainwright to escobar
hit the other way and that's a base hit
wong
is being waved in the throw to the plate
it's in time the tag ow
he's out of the play outfield assess
tyler o'neill well i thought wong may
have slid under the tag but the home
plate umpire chris guccione our crew
chief as well called them out that's a
great throw i love the fact that o'neill
made the adjustment and he had a couple
of bad throws a couple of weeks ago and
what does he do here he throws it on the
money so the base is now loaded for
avisail garcia one two on a hop
tommy edmond
and the cardinals get out of a first
inning jam a little help from tyler
o'neal
bottom of the first coming up and
there's no score well amazing numbers
for corbin burns those strikeouts are
good for second in the league the iron
run average third making start number
seven against the cardinals and he rips
one back up the middle of thomas right
there on the shift and edmond is retired
on a hot shot
short lead at first by nolan arnado and
the 2-2 pitch
coronado delayed steal and he's in there
safely
looked to be a delayed steal
3-2 again curveball got him big yacker
down goes o'neill
a strikeout for burns the first swing
and miss produces his first k
no score we're off and running here and
saint louis would go to the second
inning
oh two pitch swinging a fly ball hit out
towards left center slicing away from
vader dives he can't get it it's up
against the wall
rowdy teles digs into second base with a
lead-off double to start the brewers
half of inning number two
long was hit by a curveball right in the
back of the cab his first time up last
inning
long hops it up no man's land long run
and that's fair
that's right out of the reach of arnotto
it landed in fair territory that's going
to be a double for wong now the throw
gets away long on his way to third and
it hits him in the back oh man
all the way to third he goes a run will
score cardinals throwing the ball
everywhere
it's one nothing milwaukee
another one down he goes
that is a big high spin curveball right
there
corbin burns dialed in he's got a couple
of strikeouts
a three up three down second inning
yelling's ready to lead off
to lead off the third the pitch ground
ball fairball down the line and into the
corner gonna be extra bases for yelich
he turns first jogs into second and the
brewers have their lead off man aboard
in the form of christian yelich another
double for christian yelich and there's
a runner a third with less than two outs
now for omar narvaez starts with a curve
here narvia sends one to right field
that's down that is gonna go
to the wall yell it scores easily
narvaez into second base with a stand-up
double it's an rbi and it's two nothing
milwaukee went to the count
and burns back up the middle that's down
a base head
orban burns staying with it was a little
cutter by wayne wright and corbin burns
has a one-out single
oh wong gets into one left center that's
gonna get down and it bounces out
and burns to second base one out bases
loaded christian yelich against adam
wainwright two-nothing already milwaukee
the 2-2 pitch
and got him a strikeout of yelich
and his biggest strikeout of the night
another payoff from burns and he got him
right on the edge that was perfectly
placed
a cut fastball
and a backwards k for corbin burns his
third strikeout well again i mean
there's nothing that o'neal is going to
be able to do with this pit so you just
take it hope it's called a strike and
there's that low strike that doesn't get
cold all that often two ounce runner at
second molina gotta be where on this
first one and he swings at the first one
then a fly ball to right got some carry
garcia is there makes a catch in the
palm of his glove molina's upset he
flies out to right
and burns
keeps it rolling here works around a
lead-off walk trying to protect a
two-nothing lead lars newt barr
bouncing ball right to wong
and there is out number one good
comeback by burns down three and one in
the count
one pitch curve ball
in the air to right routine for avi
garcia
been a great pitch for burns tonight at
mundo sosa now with two away wainwright
spot in the order due up next
with activity in the cardinal bullpen
her ball
and right to wong the gold glover snags
it nice play to end the inning nice and
tidy for
corbin burns oh two on willie adamus
swang and a mess and he struck him out
his fourth of the night
and one two three the first one two
three for wayne oh in this ball game
we're midway through six and it's
two-nothing tommy edmond over two
grounded to short grounded to first
there it is base hit into left and the
cardinals have their first hit tonight
it comes with one out here in the bottom
of the sixth and now the tying run will
come to the plate the 01 pinch
hit up the middle base hit edmond to
second now on his way to third back to
back hitch for the cardinals
now here's tyler o'neil
and o'neill he gets jammed a little
pop-up
wong and tales are over wong calls he's
got it corbin burns just overpowering
two heavy hitters with the cardinals
saint louis strands runners at the
corners the no hitter is gone the
shutout still attacked so it's going to
be brad boxberger now hits the spot
vader strikes out and narvaez stood up
tall and voxberger put it right on the
money and a strikeout for out number two
devin williams on the pitch carpenter
will lead off and cheddar fastball right
by him devin williams his first fast
ball of the game we go to the ninth so
far to script and now josh hader trying
to finish it off one ball two strikes
oh he got him nasty slider down and in
o2 pitch
oh and a cold strike three back doordoom
dean takes a seat
second strikeout for haters harrison
bader one last piece to the puzzle for
hater and vader a swing a fly ball
shallow left yelich he's there and the
ball game is over josh hader
closes it out the brewers shut out the
cardinals
a two-nothing final tonight in saint
louis
you